I was designed to save the world
people who would look to the sky and see
hope I'll take that from them first
there's only one path to peace their
extinction try to create a suit of armor
around the world but I created something
terrible artificial intelligence
it's called the Ultron program I'm sick
of watching people pay for our mistakes
isn't why we fight so we can end the
fight and go home
well you amazingly failed
and we all are
nothing but our wit and our will save
world so stand and fight
no way we all get through this I got no
plans tomorrow night
I'm always picking up after you boys
we can tear them apart
from the enzyme
got the best you can do
yeah
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my breakdown of this final
Ultron footage obviously we get to see
the vision lots of cool stuff I'm also
giving away a subscription to the Marvel
collector Corps that's like their Funko
pop giveaway thing it's the only way to
get the Hulkbuster Funko so I'll
announce the winner of that next week
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment below so
let's go so this is a better shot of
Ultron's lair and sokovia that's the
fictional country where this is taking
place it sounds a lot like this Kurt
music run where he took over this
fictional country called slur enniaa
this shot here at from the end of the
trailer it looks very similar to this
shot from the comic book so I think a
lot of the story was lifted from this we
get confirmation that Ultron is working
with Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch or he
coops their services it'll be
interesting to see what happens to make
them switch sides and help the Avengers
this shot here is obviously the new
quinn chen it's also an allusion to
ultron and the vision just two sides of
the same coin joss whedon's teased them
as being this cain and abel type story
you no-good brother bad brother so when
he says there's only one path to peace
their extinction he's talking about man
in general like all of man not just the
avengers and here's where the
destruction porn starts new shot of the
Avengers tower in this movie all the
Avengers are living in this if you
remember at the end of the first
Avengers film when Tony Stark was
looking at the plans with Pepper Potts
they have rooms for all the Avengers
this is a shot of Ultron putting himself
together it looks like this jumps
backwards in time like that first time
the Ultron crashes in on the party and
he's made him an old Iron Man drone that
looks like it got blown up in an
explosion this looks like it leads up to
that Joss Whedon said that we would see
an evolution to Ultron they even showed
this is actually the picture of ultron
1.0 tony stark kind of explains it in
this scene too he starts out as a
peacekeeping program that evolved during
the shatori invasion in the first
Avengers film and then as some things
got the rails and he starts to evolve
when he says he was trying to wrap the
world in a suit of armor what he was
trying to do was create an army of Iron
Man drones to do the job of the Avengers
and cleaning up Hydra cleaning up the
world in general too but but mostly
taking care of the biggest threats ever
since the end of Winter Soldier the
Avengers have been flying all over the
world cleaning up messes so they're
super exhausted and Tony Stark is like
wait I got a plan I could totally build
robots to do this for us what could go
wrong with Apple
and here's more confirmation on the
Bruce Banner black widow relationship
this is the money shot here with all the
Avengers flying through the air at the
same time done this snowy hill chase
it's funny because if you saw the Ninja
Turtles movie they did a shot exactly
like that
where the Ninja Turtles were in a fight
while they were flying down a hill
that's Loki's scepter with the mind gem
in it a lot of people are wondering what
this is it just looks like an advanced
shield carrier taking people to safety
it could be Iron Man's mobile Armory in
the comics he has an armory that he
flies around with them that has all
kinds of different armors depending on
what his needs are Captain America
laying it into Ultron final boss form
with his shield it's kind of up in the
air as to how Wakanda figures into this
movie because we don't meet Black
Panther until Captain America Civil War
but Ultron in the comics has always
wanted to get his hands on vibranium to
make himself as strong as possible
ulysses klaw supposed to be in the film
so we could get some teasers for
vibranium maybe not black widow picking
up Captain America's shield there was a
lot of teasers earlier about everyone
trying to pick up Thor's hammer and
black widow in the comics has picked up
Thor's hammer I think there'll be a lot
of playing around with different
Avengers picking up other Avengers
weapons I don't think we're gonna see
any other characters wield Thor's hammer
though that would be awesome
Captain America picking up Thor's hammer
for real when Ultron says we can tear
them apart from the inside he's talking
about Scarlet Witch taking control of
their minds so he might get some really
twisted flashbacks she also might be
mind controlling the Hulk here just
because this shot comes right after he
said that am i controlling the Hulk to
go crazy on everyone this shot of Iron
Man dragging the Hulk up the building is
actually kind of a reverse shot of the
Hulk Catching Iron Man flying down in
the first Avengers film here's
confirmation of that so here's Scarlet
Witch actually controlling black widows
mind Quicksilver giving it to cap we
don't really know what the extent of
scarlet witch's powers are gonna be but
it looks like she has a form of tactile
Kinesis so it looks like she's gonna be
throwing him around quite a bit too and
this is a nice mirror for that Avengers
Assemble moment you know in the camera
spun around them in the first Avengers
film they started taking it to the shoot
our II Thor challenges Ultron so Ultron
sends his army of replicants after him
it even looks like Iron Man has
different armor in this than he does
earlier in the trailer it's kind of hard
to tell
so his armor might change throughout the
film just like it did in the first
Avengers film here
his final shot of final boss form Ultron
if you remember there was promo footage
of him from comic-con where he looked
different so that might be his second
form before he turns himself into this
this is what leads to that promo art
that they released last year to the
Avengers getting buried in replicants
and here we see the vision I wonder how
many color swatches it took to get him
right Joss Whedon said that they spent
forever just trying to get the color of
his face right that shade of red which I
think it's kind of funny and if we look
here does this not look like the soul
gem from Thanos his gauntlet don't want
to call it too soon but I believe that
the soul gem is what makes the vision
vision he obviously starts out as AI but
he has a soul he has a silicon salt
that's a big part of the character and
the soul gem would be the logical way
within the context of this movie to
explain that you guys can let me know if
you agree though do you think that this
is the soul gem I know there's a lot of
question as to how he gets created in
the film he's gonna save the day
obviously he's gonna turn on Ultron but
we don't know if they changed it so that
Tony Stark also created the vision or if
it's like the comic books and Ultron
created him the matically I think it's a
little bit better if they follow the
comics but they've already changed so
much so I'm not gonna freak out if they
change even more so let me know what you
guys think of this trailer let me know
you're most excited about it you're
seeing this personally I'm most jazzed
up about the vision I really want to see
him in action my next bonus Avengers
video is probably gonna be a Scarlet
Witch video just a character video from
my favorite Scarlet Witch stories from
the comics just because I haven't done a
video on her yet so be sure to subscribe
to get that feel free to leave a request
though I'm working on a new arrow video
for a death in the family like Batman
death in the family so I'm gonna explain
that from the comics for those that
haven't read that story run well you
guys wait for that to drop you can click
here for my top 5 Ultron stories from
the comics and you can click here to
catch up on agents of shield it came
back last night they're doing Inhumans
it's gonna be awesome
thanks so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight now let's all do the thing
you